[Musique]
bienvenue dans face à la première une
autre émission politique hebdomadaire
que vous pouvez suivre donc
aussi bien sur nos réseaux sociaux casio
notre radio martinique première est
partout n'est ce pas aujourd'hui j'ai
anime l'émission en compagnie de
maurizio le tombeau jour maurice bonjour
manquons soir à toutes et à tous et en
face de vous se trouve notre invité qui
est un homme politique qui a qui a mis
volontairement fait à tous ses mandats
électoraux avant d'être éventuellement
battus ou d'être poussé vers la sortie
s'est enclenchée bonjour bonjour ma
partie vous jouez les yeux le ton je ne
pensais pas qu on pousserait et ce n'est
pas la raison pour laquelle déjà reçu
partie mais vous avez le dit souvent que
les sénateurs sont des hommes sages
il faut savoir prendre la bonne décision
au bon moment vous avez été sénateur
jusqu au 2 octobre dernier date de la
rentrée parlementaire au sénat
vous avez occupé beaucoup de mandat
électif depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années je peux de rappeler brièvement
parce que la cie sinon on y passerait
une bonne partie de l'émission vous avez
été 2 fois sénateur d'ailleurs il ya
aucun politique martiniquais qui neuf
effectuer plus de deux mandats au sénat
en tout cas sous sol haïti cinquième
république je rappelle que vous avez été
mais en du diamant depuis 1988 pendant
vingt ans jusqu'en 2008 vous avez été
conseiller général du canton
la même année 1988 tu seras 2004 vous
avez été aux côtés de claude lise
président du conseil général son premier
vice président vous avez présidé
l'association des maires de martinique
que vous avez bien dynamisé durant votre
mandat on s'en souvient également et
oserais-je dire que vous avez été dans
une autre vie professeur d'histoire
géographie et de lettres qu'est ce qui
vous est resté de cette profession quand
vous avez quitté avec regret m'en vais
vous confier il y a de cela oui c'est le
côté style le manque de contact avec un
jeunesse et puis le plaisir que j'avais
dans seuil est d'apporter quelque chose
il fait connaître le monde aggravés sur
dano à nous à nos enfants
vous savez il faut bien se connaître
pour bien embrasser le monde
il faut savoir connaît son histoire son
passé et moi je m'impliquais à donner
jeune martiniquais peut-être bien fait
avec du kansas à ses côtés de l'an passé
juste une petite précision j'ai pour
dire quand vous avez atterri au ppm
alors que vous avez été longtemps divers
gauche mouvement enfin par un mouvement
un ensemble d'élus qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui puisque maintenant tout le
monde est en quarantaine dans une
formation politique à 26 formations
politiques en martinique je le rappelle
donc c'était quelques semaines avant les
élections sénatoriales en 2011
d'ailleurs vous avez été lus et ça avait
fait un peu jaser vous souvenez de ce
moment là même si c'était un mauvais
souvenir mais mais vous savez en fait
j'étais très proche du but du ppm depuis
très longtemps et il ne pas oublier que
quand comme le maire de gaubert ses
besoins terroriste relatives aux
doubistes hâtives la seule commune où il
a eu la majorité c'est la miel c'est
vous dire est que lorsque je lis pas ce
que conseille génère de la pratique a
basculé et bien c'est parce que je
venais de la grue au conseil général
donc j'étais dans cette pauvre ça y est
t'es con vous l'avez dit suppliant déjà
nous disiez sénateurs ppm autrement dit
ils avaient déjà fait le travail
j'ai fait le show mais il veut s'excuser
bethenod passez-vous d'officialiser la
chose la démarche
ben oui quand serge larcher lorsqu'on
vous écoute on voit souriant heureux de
votre parcours politique est quand même
certains n'ont pas hésité à dire tout au
long de cette longue carrière que
jean-marc vient de retracer que si vous
avez pu faire autant de choses hein la
liste est longue
c'est parce que finalement peut-être que
serge larcher si le prototype même du
parfum en zoller à la demande us a
jamais entendu ça mais toujours à gauche
toujours à gauche est toujours de ma
famille modérée de la gauche je n'arrive
saviez sentir mensonge a bien volé j'ai
depuis toujours il était toujours dans
le camp de la gauche était non inscrits
donc donc partie passerelle l'époque ne
permettait pas dépasser pas seulement de
qatif le seul enjeu ne s'envolent pas je
vais te vois tu as vu la stratégie là ça
sera tout à fait un bateau bus nous mais
je sais ce que je veux et qui sait ce
qu'il veut mais se met à sa disposition
de meilleures armes pour les obtenir ces
résultats savez l'art dans cette affaire
c'est d'avoir des objectifs
il est clair pour soi pour sont payés
ours au peuple ivoirien vous y retrouver
des clercs et les moyens d'y parvenir
on était bon je viens savoir les
analyser et prenez les bonnes décisions
au bon moment alors avant la moitié j'ai
souvent était l'homme qu'il fallait à la
passe qu'il fallait il est tout ce qu on
peut alors avant d'aller plus loin est
ce qu'on doit dire aujourd'hui serge
larcher
bonjour ou bonsoir monsieur le sénateur
honoraire
comment grosse fois je ne sais que je
n'ai pas vu je ne vois pas la nuit
autun leur bonjour ça va
le sénateur honoraire pour mais je vais
bien je suis séance un sénateur de la
république ça me va parfaitement
et puis je suis et j'y suis ce que je
suis un mais disons que je n'ai pas de
regrets j'ai pris une décision parce
qu'il fallait pas selon moi il n'y a pas
que la vie politique dans la vie il ya
la vie aussi et à ses amis que j'ai
beaucoup n'est figé il y à là sa famille
ou ma famille que j'ai beaucoup négliger
il ya un moment pour tous j'ai donné
beaucoup à la baltique pas suffisamment
je pense donner encore d'autres fort
exode quelle forme non mais je veux que
je peux former la jeunesse que
conseiller je peux apporter bon mais
éclairage mon esprit gaza à tous ceux
qui veulent et sont des sections de deux
partis politiques je suis là ouvert à
tous ceux qui veulent faire avancer mon
pays
vous vous sentez l'absence de contrainte
désormais sur vos épaules vous sentez
plus libre depuis que vous avez mis un
terme à cette à ce mandat de cette
fonction de sénateur qui n'ont voulu
attendre quelques semaines sentir plus
libre
parce que jusqu'à présent je suis très
sollicité et peut-être que les gens
n'ont pas compris que j'avais laissé des
différents mandats mais j'ai toujours
été très sollicités même avant d'être
maire envahi les thermes est toujours
été son unité société et parce que vous
savez pourquoi
parce que dans la vie en fait vous
faites des choses et et finalement à
bien y regarder c'est que vous pouvez
sans vouloir inconsciemment vous mettez
en situation et les gens et les gens
perçoivent les choses comme ça voilà
j'ai besoin de telles démarches ou bien
tel ou tel des marques tels
renseignements
mais voilà celui qui celui qui peut pas
inventer d'éclairage et on
à vous alors jusqu'à présent il n'a pu
oublier que chez les sénateurs
continuent en basse politique tu es bon
j'essaie de faire de mon niveau
sollicité sujet martin a surtout des
sortes de dossiers
il faut que la base voilà assuré on a pu
prouver qu'ils n'ont pas dire déjà été
farouchement opposés 40% farouchement à
des malades ou trois de mes rêves et
bien eric doligé on a trouvé que les
gens sont venus en exemple parce qu'il
faut que toucher du doigt la réalité et
il n'avait pas cette connaissance y
parle des dépenses et des cocotiers de
bons mais oui mais fallait il suffira de
rester c'était bien je vous dit rien il
suffit pas d'aller prendre le micro et
et puis un plateau pour chaque fois
grâce aux côtés d'une chose il faut
aller vers les gens expliqué et
pédagogue expliquer les réalités et aux
méfaits des voyous place les choses que
j'avais plusieurs fois ce n'est certes
pas joué en particulier
c'est une fille on y voit ici en 2009
foire est survenu sur place c'est celle
là sur les baladeurs et ben voilà on a
mené les gens on emmène les gens et sous
la ceinture et / ou même supermarché
également pouvoir à tour leurs anciennes
je voulais en service les gens même
acheter des produits pour faire vous
montrer la différence le différentiel je
vous dis peut y avoir des dossiers qui
sont relatés attendre parce qu'on a
posté un drop en thèse que 6 ou les dlcs
et chaussées limite de consommation
n'est pas moi on n'est pas là c'est que
j'ai constaté que c'est debout lui
feraient les dlc ici sont plus la marge
est bouclée on the rocks à paris pour le
nouveau de lui mais dont il ya quand
même des choses à voir à revoir donc
nous sommes en selle au mans par ses
valises c'est vrai ça veut dire que ça
veut dire que c'est le des traces et que
le fonctionnement de l'état et dont le
pays libéral s'est dit qu'il n'y a pas
de contrôles suffisants et aux trois
mois dit aujourd'hui tant prônée par le
taux de sucre est de constater que le
taux de sucre n'a pas bougé constaté un
changement dans vos sorbet dans le sud
il ya beaucoup parlé mais oui mais pour
beaucoup de choses le problème pour
djebbour ceci est un cri au gouvernement
mais je leur ai demandé quels sont les
résultats
autrement dit quand avez vous contrôlez
une évolution c'est à dire que quand je
veux tu nous as police
attention nous risquons le diable de
produits de 2 des maladies à la
martinique
voilà les causes sont là dans les
produits
et aujourd'hui ça qu'il faut faire c'est
d'abord mesuré allait tenter et mesure
pouvoir s'il ya une sélection où j'écris
j'ai de moi écrit personne ne répond pas
quand je vais te poses la question
d'investir parce que toujours de l'avant
du pont alors serge larcher puisque
aujourd'hui vous êtes allé la parole
libre vous n'êtes plus en fonction josip
on a toujours été libre disait-elle de
très bons pays alors vous pouvez
peut-être les choses plus franchement
aujourd'hui j'ai dit les choses
franchement est ce que quelque part ce
n'est pas du mépris vis-à-vis des
populations de nos pays
cette façon de faire cette façon de voir
leur dit des choses on dit oui puis
finalement bague et la qualité la faune
sans nom mais je ne peux pas je ne
dirais pas la même chose je dis
simplement c'est le système des bateaux
n'est pas beau vous avez vu vous
annoncer en libéral notre contrôle par
contre le prix libre marché qui établit
le juste prix
bon autant de qualités finalement
aujourd'hui on me fait confiance
et bien c'est fait la marge autrement
dit on a fait une oie le problème
aujourd'hui le problème fondamental dans
la langue française c'est que nous
faisons des lois collectivement le
parlement fait des lois mais où personne
ne vient évaluer c'est l'efficacité de
ces bois comme tous ces patrons parlent
ou trop bien c'est pas tout ça ne s'est
pas égaré bora les mois au jour nous
avons fait nous avons fait on a obtenu
la défiscalisation pour le tourisme en
mai personnes évalue c'est l'exemple
flagrant on revient sur les destinations
c'est parce que ça coûte cher mais c'est
pas parce qu on apprend que le
dispositif est bon ou mauvais on va vous
dire c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'évaluation sur les politiques
publiques dites moi monsieur le sénat
pour toute la france évalue la facture
et comme nous sommes en difficulté
vraiment et bien c'est encore plus
valable
monsieur larcher ça n'est ce pas là la
faute des parlementaires on ne met pas
également l'outil pour mesurer pour
quantifier sais c'est pas de la
dépendance et parfois de manger des
fruits maintenant mais là le parlement
fait la loi et il appartient à
l'exécutif de l'exacte d'exécuter de
contrôler
déduction tous nous sommes 2 face à la
première avec serge larcher ancien
sénateur ppm de martinique anciennement
diamant entre autres fonctions électives
personnellement vous avez passé 13 ans
et 13 ans jusqu'à un premier mandat de
sept ans qu'on va pas rentrer dans le
détail puisqu'il y avait un mandat de
sept ans 2004 et puis six ans après
finalement avec un peu de recul même
s'il ya quelques semaines seulement que
vous nommiez plus quelle action de
laquelle vous êtes le plus fier vous
montrez vous le plus fier c'est ce qui
attend d'action mais je pense que cdc
plusieurs coups sélection se montrer
alors il ya la création d'un lieu de
suite la création d'années que la
délégation tout ben ça c'est moi que les
portes et on m'a proposé le poste de
vice président jeudi vous refusez j'ai
demandé la création de cela ça froisse
essentiel parce que ça c'est un
investissement pour l'avenir
au travail votre mère il ya une
structure dédiée première c'est pour
cette raison que je disais souvent à mes
collègues qui voulait je compte écrire
un groupe marais nous avons quelque
chose à dire nous avons un dispositif
vous apprécierez qu'elle est
actuellement présidée par bruno maroc et
sénateurs républicains sont majoritaires
a fauté nous avons jugé autre chose
c'est que très bonne heure pour les gens
qui veulent être pour l'autonomie de la
martinique et pour tous ceux qui
m'aiment ce qui serait déportée c'est
que ce que le patrimoine martiniquais
reviennent à la barre titre vienne où
martiniquais
c'est à dire les équipages aux batteries
à terme en 2020 deux présidents
devraient tous la bonne sécurité gérés
par l'ademe celle qui est un coffret qui
gérait pas louer nef qui n'est pas
cessible
tout ça tu seras tu te devrait
transférer patrimoine martiniquais la
région c'est un bon temps comme on dit
nous nous remet nous revenons c'est la
patrie bosse à terme rappelé qu'elle
voyait sous contrôle martinique c'est
pourtant très important mais ouais c'est
bien je vais vous laisser vous je suis
un de ceux là avec cette chimie en
particulier nous avons pu entonner cela
est votre plus grand regret comme
sénateur
à mon plus grand regret est amusant vous
savez je suis un mardi je vais sortir
des sorties un petit peu de limerick
fait de décider peut-être sage mais pour
agresser c'est d'être resté muet ne pas
pouvoir dire à quelqu'un pas un ministre
à nos clients ce musée du budget
socialiste
le mot que tous les martigues et
connaissent lorsqu'ils n'obtiennent pas
parce que c'est mon but
si vous voulez mais après ça s'est passé
mais je vois que j'ai ce livre tout
simplement parce qu'il avait osé dire
jour par la tribune
j'ai déjà d'un abonnement que vous nabot
demant de cours ne soient ceux qui ne
concerne pas la partie pour se pratiquer
dans ce groupe i can't locaux c'était
pour la zone tempérée gens vont se dit
autrement dit pour l'hexagone
je me dis ne sont pas la face à la
pression puisqu'elle ne s'était pas un
sujet je suis viendront vous ai parlé ce
sujet sur la transposition des
dispositions législatives pour la bo
pour la métropole la chaleur transposé
pour la martinique aux pays de la rive
le froid alors pourquoi n'avait pas osé
jeu jeudi jolly je dire je vois ça j'ai
dit à force que français mais il savait
qu'on était chez nous à ses dirigeants
mais on est satisfait quand ça sort et
ça vous fait du bien
et là j'ai appris c'est vrai c'était la
foulée on avait rencontré d'après moi ça
s'arrête dès ma sortie
ah si si j'en ai expliqué mon bon
français alors justement en parlant de
trois maires qui coûte cher tout à
l'heure vous disiez que la
défiscalisation veut être régulièrement
supprimer aura beauté depuis une
quinzaine d'années saison les
gouvernements de droite et de roches
ce même magasin parce que nous coûtant
trop cher et il ya quelques jours leur
le rapport annuel de la cour des comptes
a été publié encore une fois bon
l'outre-mer beaucoup trop cher en
l'occurrence les collectivités quatre
des cinq départements d'outre-mer et
territoires et collectivités coup trop
cher parce qu'il ya trop de personnel
trop bien payé puisqu'il
-la prime dite de vie chère avec des
indexations différentes que selon que
l'on soit à la réunion ou à saint pierre
et miquelon et donc une fois de plus
notre mère est cloué au pilori mais oui
la présentation du quotidien de ces
sorties là il a des outre mer en ligne
de mire il a fait plus de sorties déjà
sur l'octroi de mer rappelez vous c'est
là aussi où il a gracié les
fonctionnaires ils assurent les bus
assurent les fonctionnaires sous la
veste défiscalisation en fait de
toujours nous ce n'est pas faire
exception du nombre des réfugiés
c'est vrai les gars du cil mais il est
où ici mais il faut savoir
il me dit à mayotte il est venu à la
réunion il est venu mais il faut
attendre les gens viennent il faut pas
les recevoir il faut le dire les vérités
faut pas être de celui qui a créé à tort
à tout vent non il faut dire les choses
vraiment c'est moi je disais des choses
que j'ai déjà des gens qui ont changé de
couleur de bon moi parce que je devais
de la vérité j'avais 12 ans je dis ce
que je pense que vous dite prête à de
l'eau était à mon pays je dis aux gens
ce que j'ai à dire et et là il n'y a pas
de langue de bois et il faut leur dire
ça il faut le toucher il faut dire dire
les choses clairement mais sans pouvoir
sans agresser pourtant d'être ils
connaissent pas n'importe quoi ils
disent n'importe quoi est ce monsieur
l'a dit n'importe quoi
il sait pas que nous avons nous avons
sûrement zones tropicales humides que
les quais que les machines ont une durée
de vie beaucoup plus coûteux les
ordinateurs ne tiennent pas debout
les arbres qui lui arrive à transcender
toutes ces choses
une fois que deux d'école à la
martinique à la barre et ses dix ans et
dix au maximum et en fasse beaucoup
d'espacé comme sur le pays de neuf que
nous avons quoi faire d authentifier et
que ça coûte cher que nous avons un tout
chemin très important que nous faisons
vous avez dit vous avez des associés
offre un but social nouvelle à papeete
nous rappelons le maximum distribuer des
revenus famille il sait pas toutes ces
choses là il s'est passé pour les
commerçants il refuse le sans pareil
mais non vision qui doit fuir ce lundi
qu'ils nous regardent avec avec les
lunettes des critères français avec des
normes françaises et ça nous sommes en
zone tropicale humide jamais voté
ce qui est petit jeu solide il avait
fait voter
je veux une part au sénat la première
voiture il nous parle de d'ultra périph
cité de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement la prise en compte de
tous ces handicaps que nous avons pour
donner du bon ok c'est plus cher dans
tous les sens ça démonte et préviennent
que vous écoutez bien c'est des beautés
seulement qui s'est passé à l'assemblée
nationale ça a été supprimé mais jamais
gagné j'ai tout le temps mais ça se
passe bien jusqu'à présent nous n'avons
pas alors la dg la dg dont on parle
beaucoup c'est une bagasse
essentiellement gouvernement la mission
d'un élu du rebond on va voir la police
allait voir où s'ébat les voir les gens
qu'il faut pas aller pleurer il faut
aller vous les arguments et vous
défendez votre corps votre problème
alors est-ce qu'on ne se trompe pas dans
la façon de mener ces combats là depuis
le temps qu'on mène ces combats mais je
vous assure un bain vous avez souvent
dit que j'aime beaucoup souffrir mais je
souris mais il ya le sourire ça c'est la
forme
et puis à ce que je dis c'est qu'il le
faut et je peux dire des choses réduira
souvient peut-être
et là il faut se battre il faut arrêter
de jouer à vis aujourd'hui dès le départ
il faut travailler aller dans ce dossier
vous n'aimez pas les plairait d exiger
pepo dit j'ai des arguments des faits du
concret c'est ça qui verrait d'avancé
pour les compagnies sont nationales et
qu'on prenne finalement mais toujours
comme vous l'avez dit pour entrer en
cloud 1 il faut taper plusieurs fois sur
la tête du cloud c'est pas nous c'est
bien c'est pour vous tous de bata
pédagogie revenir revenait ainsi on
obtient des choses mais on arrive quand
on avance mais c'est pas facile
c'est pour cette raison que je vous dise
et il faut être des guerriers et
l'élection de madame ocon à la
succession
comme je suis un guerrier un poids
justement c'est la bonne personne est ce
que le niveau de capacité pour être
sénatrice elle a toutes les qualités
qu'il faut
elle a des élèves sont réellement quel
poids voulait de son débit ou bruxelles
je pense que c'est une personne qui a la
détermination qu'à la volonté puis vous
avez vu serge larcher
ce com
on en parlait avec un jaguar partie
cette semaine déjà sur ce dossier dès
des quotas de cannes à bord et on a
quand même eu ce document signé par les
deux sénateurs quelque part vous vous le
désormais nouveau retraité de la
politique ça vous fait plaisir de voir
les six parlementaires si c'est très
bien d'avoir fait ça c'est que ces
normes vesa il faut justement les plus
loin saisir chaque pas chaque assemblée
le parlement d'adopter l'assemblée pour
voter une ppr eux faites-nous pouvoir
sur des solutions pour faire pour
appuyer justement cette démarche n'a
dans cette démarche dans cette une est
démarre cliquez sur le rhône a pour
qu'on comprenne vraiment ça peut
vraiment pesé que l'encens que la
totalité des scellements since he has a
lieu c'est vraiment et applaudir c'est
très très content pour nous mêmes mais
arrivé le courrier arrive et signé sur
les bureaux parisiens s'apaisent ça pèse
bien il faut continuer à évoluer c'est
un élément de notre combat c'est pas le
seul élément vous dis que ça mais il
faut aller interpeller à l'oral à
l'écrit encore il faut essayer de faire
une pub est dangereux d'y saisir au
parlement pour pouvoir obtenir quelque
chose pas laisser le cadre
institutionnel le cadre administratif le
fait que nous soyons que nous relevions
de l'antique 73 de la constitution même
si une certaine liberté de manoeuvre
n'est pas finalement trop contraignant
par rapport à ce que nous souhaitons aux
aspirations de la population aux
problèmes que nous avons à régler aux
souhaits de nos élus de casser un peu
certain nombre de cadres venant de
bureau est-ce qu'il faut pas progressé
est ce que c'est le cadre mais parle
finalement gênant est obsolète
vous avez aujourd'hui si vous si vous
allez encore ouvrir un truc de canal
pour le week-end tissot cela va marcher
il avait bien être de chaque fois
l'équipe marché donc avec tbt le deux
buts le club pour sauver vous connaissez
lastic timon l'élastique au maximum de
la soirée entrer le maximum de choses
vous avez un diplôme assise territoriale
la diplomatie territoriales ils étaient
tous contre s'est passé pendant la crise
entre le maximum et obtenons ainsi des
avancées c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
prendre c'est pas seulement un programme
pourtant vous à l'échelle locale
et puis vous avez
quand vous écoutez dissensions de la wii
et y narre combat qu'a fait le conseil
général la région bloquée national de
gamache et travestis et la ligne à
celles abritant et brave vous les avez
vous dit arrêtons de parler des câbles
et te parler de contenu et tous les
choses avancent à l'instant semble
apparemment chez vous en vous adhérez à
la vie de 10 ans sont la 7e le
fonctionnement votre analyse
non j'ai pas des titres sont des choses
de son sommet et de sagesse et la base
et vous nous écoutez moi c'est une
glaciation
c'est une glaciation l'évolution un
homme de la même paire témoin pêcheurs
ils vont y arriver ça dépanne yvan magny
cours
quand doivent être placés dans l'année
tous ces sales à mardyck c'est ça
aujourd'hui c'est dramatique parce que
on sait bien que c'est la commande
publique qui tire le bateau martinique
et si vous n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas
seul à rien ne marche ses autres
secteurs ne s'avance pas donc on
approuve sa pauvre y ait aujourd'hui si
la lecture de votre parti politique
serge marché je suis en phase avec la
lecture c'est une analyse qui vient
d'une analyse mais c'est une réalité qui
sont sans le voir si ce sont des partis
politiques
il le dit il dit qu'aujourd'hui bon on
ne sait quels sont les caps quelles sont
les orientations qu elles sont des
projets écoutez voici royal puisse
ramener des points c'est beaucoup
je ne sais pas où allons nous où allons
nous en sommes nous moi je ne sais pas
moussu place doit avancer tout va pour
avancer dans une eau glacée
nour a fait sur place notre calme ici
avec le risque de discrédit sur
l'ensemble de la classe est parfaitement
c'est ça c'est toujours ainsi parce que
ça ne marche pas c'est au début on
stigmatise stigmatise et après tout le
monde qui à présent programme ce qu'il
faut dit aujourd'hui il faut que les
gens se ressaisissent et je pense que
tout le monde est prêt à faire à mettre
la main à la pâte pour pouvoir dessiner
quelques perspectives d'avenir pour
sortir l'avant sans grand mal à de la 7e
le mandat des élus de la collectivité
territoriale n'est pas finie et finit en
mars 2000 vient d'appuyer encore jeune
mais c'est pas morizet vous pourrez
temps dès que c'est le calme plat
espérons qu on sort de ce cadre le placo
quelqu'un en face de souk ainsi conçu
que si la population se fait bouger par
un becquet avant c'est ça le soir vous
avez remarqué que si j'avais un petit
avant de parler de projet acté une
structure projets à venir ou du quad et
non justement donné de nous votre avis
là-dessus parce que il ya quelques jours
on a quand même senti que je pouvais
avoir quelques remous c'est de l'équipe
dirigeants de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique avec yan
monplaisir qui chef de la droite au sein
de cette coalition qui disait qu'il y
avait un manque de confiance du secteur
de grigny de la population à cause de
cette inaction dit-il de l'équipe au
pouvoir vous mais j'ai entendu plusieurs
son coach au temps du second volet de
dinars aborder cela et puis on m'a dit
aussi que que à la radio à la télévision
et on a dit autre chose on a minoré
c'est exactement ce qu'on a dit qu'on
m'a dit on attend vous avez vous invité
bientôt monsieur mon plaisir
j'entendais revoir enfin les bornes mais
c'était c'est un petit but natuelles
vous savez le factuel vous faites la fin
août il a croqué soirée pour coin mais
justement vous disiez tout à l'heure que
vous avez vous militiez pour que les
élus politiques en face de
responsabilité haddock de sa femme
d'orientation parlent d'une même voix au
delà de leurs différences politiques
mais sur pourquoi ce serait pas possible
ici qu'est ce qui empêchera la droite
parce que vu un cholet comme parce que
si la démarche elle est uniquement
négatif à dire on fait d'ailleurs contre
quiconque que quelqu'un bon salavas
absolument rien c'est ça la basse ainsi
qu'aux totalement négatif mais si vous
faites si on avait dans cette alliance
des perspectives qui est l art le dit
voilà c'est la direction qui définit
voilà où nous ne voulons arriver at-elle
échéant sténopé chez un autre chose nous
aurions compris mais ce n'est pas sa
gaieté c'est un de ceux ci pensent quand
je dis simplement que c'est une alliance
qui n'est pas faite sous la base
d'accords de projet mais sur la base
d'accords contre c'est à dire qu'on
s'est placée en 2001
battre on va pas faire avancer leur
dignité
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
vous parlez de non mais attendez
d'éléments trois exemples que vous aimez
vous avez toujours invincible chez déjà
le faire revenir et georges donné au
projet passionnant je vous explique je
suis prêt mais vous personnellement vous
auriez été conseiller du président de
l'assemblée
votre ancien camarade claude lise je
sais pas ce que vous continuer d'avoir
des relations compte en banque tout le
monde vous auriez été conseillé de
positionner passé exécutif alfred
marie-jeanne vous pouvez leur susurrer
une idée d'un projet structurant de
capcom vous dites vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous avez été élu local vous
avez il y a eu la meilleure chose à
faire
écoutez moi il ya sa visibilité
politique et alors nous sommes entre
nous sommes libres tu chériras la mer la
mer et d'autres à venir l'essayer
nous avons aujourd'hui la partie c'est
mille fois 5325 mètres carrés auxquels
il donne économique exclusive depuis les
accords de monter gober de terrain de 2
ha voir des 47 mille kilomètres dans la
mer s'ils auraient de la mer de la mer
il y a beaucoup de richesse il ya la mer
ils l'utilisent poisson il ya toute la
pharmacopée il ya henda il y a les
algues hop on peut utiliser l'énergie
réseau carburant il ya les énergies
naturelles bien sûr et vous avez besoin
tout ce qui se joue ce plancher des
océans série de l'audi métalliques
vous avez de sauce océans
alors aujourd hui tout le monde bouge
tout notre bourges nous avons là une
possibilité bouger sous cette affaire-là
c'est impossible il bougeait et il faut
repenser à la fois la pêche à la
martinique
il faut approcher la mer à la martinique
c'est pas seulement les plaisirs il ya
une mine de choses de développement là
et c'est ça nous nous étions dans le
bassin caraïbe au pied de la lettre du
continent américain au milieu du quota
mais que nous avons des perspectives
d'avenir
c'est en cela que la démocratie pas la
démocratie est important que nous
pouvons pas être forcément tout seul
mais nous avons aujourd'hui des gens qui
sont capables de jouer à l'école quand
même a réussi un double de celle ci à la
martinique
dans une première générale nous a offert
une parenthèse dans les faits s'est
posée là dessus on a vu qu'on a
beaucoup de diplômés beaucoup de gens
archi diplômé qui sont dans tous de par
le monde donc nous avons des
possibilités ya déjà des doigts ce que
disait jean luc mélenchon lorsqu'il
était venu ici à bohain oui le départ la
martinique que la martinique se tourner
davantage vers la mer mille à martigues
doit surtout les choses à venir à
martigues doivent surtout les verts son
bassin caraïbes vers ses voisins en
beauté ses voisins et doit se trouver au
kursaal à berne du marais ou d'occasion
mais c'est évident que c'est ça ou à
louer et pour qui s'est immolé non il
faut aller là il faut la répéter
je le dis de claudia bon moi je le dis
encore il faut embrasser la mère la mère
celle à venir notre avenir
si tu es sûre si le danger la mère
écoutait pas la mer c'est un danger le
sait bien c'est un danger on sait
parfaitement la main aussi nous nous
blocks historiquement nous sont venus
par la mer et nous avons aussi cette pop
scaron de se souvenir qu'on doit très
font moins de tours être même qui dit
que nous a embarqués un lieu qui était
hostile et nous avons gelé mis en examen
dans le cadre tandis que nous avons plus
d'un quart des hommes qui venaient vers
le monde qui en qui avait comme seul les
seuls l'océan du procès ça et vous vont
traverser le bourg de la martinique
ouais bien que sur tout l'univers il
doit la merde comme à nice et d'une
quelque chose d'inconscient donc mais
cela il faut faire tout cela il faut
dépasser cela il faut aller à la
conquête de la mère et la mère celle de
philosophie c'est la psychanalyse
je ne sais pas j'ai tout à la fois alors
justement vous avez évoqué le diamant
ville dont vous avez été les premiers à
nous nous ne nous gênons gt2 pas du tout
pas du tout produit des amours ib était
mon nom et mon par jeu les candidats
contre le chien a trouvé 3 il a battu et
puis après je me suis jamais laissé
guillemant est ce à ce moment là que
vous entrez alors nous avait été maire
du diamant vous avez quitté votre mandat
vous avez soutenu une candidate yvette
galot qui a été
battu par deux anciens adjoints gilbert
eustache comment vous voyez la gestion
de la ville le dynamisme du diamant
aujourd'hui alors vous voulez me ramener
au diamant non mais il suffit d'un bon
il va se dire bon il suffit de regarder
un peu ce que je peux dire la chance je
n'allais pas la cour vous ça vous dire
que bon il est calamiteuse en tout cas
il ya des grosses difficultés
bon et je ne compte jamais en mesure
d'investir encore son sourire son
potentiel d'investissement était pas
écrire il est autrement dit nous sommes
là les impôts vote ont augmenté et
l'égalisation en seconde je les cherche
de toute part il y avait une école qui a
été fait mais avec une grosse subvention
de l'état
mais c'est très bien c'est très bien
mais c'est l'espace ce qui concerne la
chaussure du diamant a beaucoup à se
réconcilier
c'est à dire que je vois une communiqué
très divisée ou voulu parce que on a
cherché à la diviser entre qui et qui
divise pas parlé mais mondialement le
gamin où je disais de ceux qui viennent
habiter au diamant et qui font de plus
en plus entendre leur voix
je parle des diamants noirs dans toutes
leurs de new york
si les autres et je ne fais pas de
détenus je savais que ce problème existe
au diamant et quel rôle la différence
allait les différences qu'il ya entre
les diamants chinois de souche et puis
les jours qui viennent d'ailleurs qu'il
existe à d'autres choses je suis pour
l'unité de la commune et vous n'avez pas
tant de mois a obtenu deux mois des
paroles qui cherchait à apporter le gère
la division
par conséquent je suis pour l'unité et
faire en sorte que tout le monde se
porte bien et se comporte bien se
comporte bien et se porte bien
le diamant et tout le corps et diamants
redevienne la grande famille qu'elle
était de diamant a su accueillir tout le
monde qu'ils ont de tout temps et que la
communique devienne une commune où il
fait bon vivre où il ya de l'harmonie de
la est là et que tout le monde aborde
l'avenir avec calais durant fauqué mais
avec avec espoir gens quand vous êtes
optimiste notre liste militants sur nos
petits du crb vous savez je redis c'est
souvent les sénateurs se désagrégeant
cette interview vous lui j'en ai vu des
vertes et des pas mûres
ça y est traversé par la vie politique
et s'empare du coup j'ai pris des coups
du coup les musiques les coups ils font
mal et puis des beaucoup de coups bas
mais j'ai toujours reçu comme l'oiseau
phoenix je relève toujours de ses
cendres
ai je déjà dense mais je ne joue pas je
ne pardonne pas mais je n'oublie jamais
pardonné mais n'oubliez pas je pardonne
je n'oublie ferrand là je parle mais je
n'oublie pas ouais serge larcher
vous avez été maire vous avez été
sénateur je sais je sais qu'on est venu
vous consultez concernant les dernières
élections
entre ceux qui vous disais ma passe
asseman poil au sénat est-ce que moi est
ce que mon nid capacité allez vous leur
dites quoi notamment on a pensé au co
présidents de communauté d'agglomération
vous aviez envie de leur dire quoi que
le véritable pouvoir il est au sénat on
va chercher le prestige au sénat ou bien
restons par exemple dans ces communautés
d'agglomération où on a le véritable
pouvoir de décider pour le développement
de la martinique en alternative ou en
complément à l'assemblée de martinez je
suis pas aigri dont vous parlez à l'âge
de président ce sont des gens qui sont
venus me voir pour la plupart de ceux et
ils sont venus me voir avec les
potentiels à londres est insuffisant
porte sénateurs cette affaire de volonté
et ce belle détermination
mais le président de parler de beaucoup
de gens et les larges et de l'art chez
lui l'avait des trois présidents de
comités l'agglomération voulait y en a
un bon il avait appris la belle et
potentiels comme on vient vous dise
potentiel est ce qu on veut
véritablement est ce constat pour
travailler on va dire les châssis s'agit
de prendre son bâton de maréchal
peaufine son sa carrière rudik saigner
pour moi moi je ne marche pas dans cette
affaire là maintenant si s'agit d'asier
réelles attaques des drones
c'est un petit peu son discours j'ai pas
dit ça non moi je vous le dis nous les
noirs ici
ah oui dans son parcours de la quotité
de son parcours est trop sénateurs
pourquoi on l'avait dit sur nos antennes
à toi ce n'est pas la même chose
pourquoi pas avoir suffisamment
d'expérience pour que ce soir la boue
dispose d'une expérience de travail pour
faire plus court ça fait c'est plus
c'est que ça c'est plus sexy d'être
sénateur ou par exemple président de
communauté d'agglomération je dis
simplement ce projet d akbou à d'autres
c'est que c'est plus utile à la
martinique être en prise directe
maintenant aujourd'hui un président de
l'économique de de bci sait qu'elle aura
de la boue et du transfert de
compétences beaucoup trop ce que vous
avez vu par les truies ski val d or il
ya les plus qui vont tomber dans son
escarcelle
il ya beaucoup de choses c'est important
lavez le transport il à hilla et
l'animation économique dans une bonne
partie dessus de la barre des scellés ne
pas s'en faire du neuf à faire pour
pauvres même à l'iedm aliéné ya des voix
il assure la vente et ses dix on les
aime important de la martinique m
le secteur important marché devrait pas
ce que c'est
il m'a semblé que c'était plus utiles a
remarqué qu'il restât en place dernière
question la démission est quasiment
touche à sa fin on a de quoi faire trois
émissions vous être authentique de la
vie politique active vous devez lui
demanda électorale mais il ya des jeunes
de on nous l'avait vu beaucoup de
candidats même si tous n'avaient pas
l'information la formation la capacité
d'être député beaucoup se sont présentés
il y aura beaucoup de candidats pour les
conseils municipaux là dans quelques 2 1
et demi quels conseils donneriez-vous à
une jeune femme un jeune homme
d'aujourd'hui disons en 35 ans qui
voudraient s'engager dans la vie
politique quelle que soit son
orientation politique gauche droite
indépendantiste ou autre qu'est-ce que
quelques conseils c'est un il vous
d'abord de s'intéresser à la chose
publique
surtout ne pas attendre le dernier
moment pour dire je suis candidat comme
si on l'avait reçue de la providence
dispose de deux messages
non il faut s'intéresser d'avoir chose
publique s'informer travailler
sérieusement connaître et obligé comme
on lit un budget comme on lirait pas des
choses comment fonctionne avant les
toners bouddhiste de tous ces éléments
qui forment la vie que l'habit dans la
cité et à partir de cela sera se met au
service de la population et le moment
viendra où on va dire que ces trois n'y
a pas dit que je suis candidat c'est
dément dit que je suis valida ça
commence à devenir compliqué compliqué
mais il faut qu'on se mette en situation
compris vous cherchez vos besoins et
grid
à ce moment là vous cette barge avant
ses valeurs pour la première fois mais
mettez-vous en situation pour se mettre
en situation
il faut aimer les gens se mettent à
disposition des gens en service
informez travailler travailler les
dossiers et avoir des choses à proposer
montrer qu'on veut servir et paso serge
et voilà et à voir les choses à proposer
et non pas aller voter donné au dernier
moment et l'adresse au sciatique ça peut
être le tremplin via sur dix est
certainement un grand merci serge
larcher d'avoir participé à face à la
première aujourd'hui en compagnie de
maurizio le ton nous
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de notre émission politique
hebdomadaire qui était réalisée
aujourd'hui par claudine et et le miel
merci à bientôt
[Musique]